welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and there are some new easy Miss
details and footage for Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania that we gotta talk
about from an IMAX version of last
week's trailer and God bless those IMAX
folks releasing footage not only in a
taller aspect ratio but actually in 4k
so that we can make out more details but
also a recent new home promo showing
Kang and his precious time chair that
Kevin feige confirmed is what he's
trying to fix to escape the quantum
realm in this movie I'm gonna break down
all the new details that we've learned
but also be sure to watch mt's excellent
breakdown of the trailer from last week
if you haven't already I loved all of
his takes on everything quantumania of
course premieres on February 17th which
is also the launch date of our new
channel the Deep dive in which I'm going
to be doing live breakdowns and
investigations with more pointed focus
and you betcha I got something playing
for quantumania so be sure to subscribe
so before we get into the IMAX 4K
details let's take a quick look at part
of this latest home teaser which I guess
really wants us to see this movie in 3D
that isn't what you think
care what he can do he's not getting out
[Music]
could win
I don't have to win we both just have to
lose so this footage shows us Kang in
that timeshare vessel that we saw in an
official Empire photo and Kevin feige
told Empire what is really going on with
this he said Kang's a very powerful
person but when we meet him he's in a
position where he needs to get that
power back he has a ship and a device
that would allow him to go anywhere and
any when he wants if he can get it
online if only he had access to genius
scientists with pin particles aha so
this sheds light on the deal that Kang
is making with Scott Scott uses his pin
particles to steal something for Kang I
think Kang is a ship and I think he
separately needs a device to power the
ship that device being a power or fuel
source so that can can repair the ship
get it back online and Kang once he can
once again navigate the time stream is
offering to manipulate timelines that
Scott can get the five years back with
Cassie but in this footage notice that
it looks like the ship breaks or might
fail to get online leading Kang to look
particularly pissed off and use his
wrist mounted beams to throw Scott down
this is my make even more sense as we go
back through the IMAX 4K version of the
footage because there are some
additional details in this trailer that
are worth discussing first there's the
photo of young Cassie on Scott's phone
Cassie has of course aged into a young
woman now played by Emma from uh
Catherine Newton but the fact that Scott
leaves her younger photo on his screen
tells us that he's sentimental and
doesn't want to update the collar photo
of Daddy's little girl or that maybe
he's still on pre-blip era of iOS and
hasn't yet figured out how to update the
photo but specifically this shot of
young Cassie is a screen grab from the
2015 Ant-Man film the exact moment that
Scott gave Cassie the ugly rabbit for
her birthday and shown in a flashback in
this trailer
so it could just be that the film is
using this stock image as a photo in the
universe or since we know that the Kang
variant he remains scripted the entire
Infinity Saga as part of his sacred
timeline and is capable of watching it
back on a film projector using these
same exact shots and angles and editing
as we saw it from this could be Kang
manipulating Scott with imagery from his
archives with the carrot that he's gonna
use to trick him into helping him one
thing not talked enough about is the
music in this trailer it is so good and
I didn't even get Elton John to do it
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
so the track in this trailer is called
the Navigator it's a collaboration
between audio machine and composer Harry
Lightfoot and of course the track title
The Navigator super appropriate giving
Kang's goal to navigate his way out of
the quantum realm organ music so intense
and haunting reminding me of Hans
Zimmer's score from Interstellar which
is also a story about a father trying to
save his daughter a daughter whose life
he misses out on thanks to time dilation
then the shot of Kang's blue mask
peeling back really fun to look at for
him by Freeman 4K the lights on the side
of his helmet flick her off first and
then there are diagonal lines across the
cheeks when the mask is still up
indicating additional reinforcement
braces within the mask that keep it
sturdy there's also this new overhead
shot of King City and in IMAX 4K all
those circular platforms really do look
like the inner gears and cogs of a
wristwatch but then this shot of the
Rings rising up has the pyramid
structure now in a taller aspect ratio
gives us a better look at the background
and actually when you compare this to
the similar shot in the October trailer
not only has the Giant Orange Vortex
been added to the sky at the top of the
pyramid if you look closely the point is
no longer an Illumina yellow tip that
yellow tip reminded me of the light
glowing from the tower The Citadel at
the end of time in Loki but here I think
it is the penthouse where Kang looks out
upon the quantum realm from it may be
turned off here in this IMAX trailer
because they don't want it to look as
artifacty but either way something is
geographically located there in the
context of the film but hey you know
what time it is Bam it's geology time
geology is the 16 time award-winning
personalized skincare company recognized
in hypebeast's birdie Men's Health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards with
over 6 000 5 Star reviews and now they
offer products for whatever you need
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you geology creates simple
and effective skin care and Hair Care
routines customized just for you with
ingredients that are proven to work no
matter what you're trying to take care
of for Hair Care youth geology's co-wash
it's a specially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses hair without the harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo geology
also has body washes that are free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
refillable for skin care geology can
protect your skin from environmental
stress with vitamin C plus e for Relic
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum-free
deodorant right now for limited time
geology is hooking our viewers up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code rockstar70 they will give you
an additional 70 off their award-winning
skincare trial set we did the math and
that's five products for just 15 on top
of that you can take an additional 30
bonus offer on one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add that to your trial
to get started just click the link in
the description now of course there's
been a lot of talk about Modoc in this
trailer and Corey stole's giant face but
the shot I'm more interested in him is
the overhead shot of all of them that
gives a profile that you can see his
nose sticking out between his head a
more three-dimensional quality yeah it
still looks weird but it's not the
two-dimensional George Lopez face really
I think this was caused by the different
parts of his body shrinking at different
rates that continued as Darren zipped
down into the quantum realm until Kang
was able to pause the process leaving
Darren's head weirdly large compared to
the rest of his body remember in the
void in Loki episode 5 there was a giant
Yellow Jacket helmet that had been
pruned from another reality though some
kinds have previously been entangled
with Darren crosses of course the most I
poppy shot of this new trailer is Scott
and what I assume is this vast Nexus Hub
pit with thousands of Scott variants
Highland upon each other like ants to
reach these huge golden bands riding on
these bands matches a circular uniform
that we first saw on the very first Set
photo for the film were the letters of
quantumania were written this way and as
Scott stands Atop The Other Ant-Man he
aims his wrist at these bands and the
red piece on his wrist activates but
remember red pin particles shrink blue
ones in large so I think he's gonna
shrink whatever this is and steal it
what is it well thanks to the IMAX 4K
version you can see that beyond the
bands are bright golden bolts of energy
which look a lot like the cracks in
reality that we see at the end of the
trailer when Kang has Scott in headlock
and various other shots that we've seen
of this location all probably part of
the same scene I think what we are
looking at is the energy source that
Kang needs to power his vessel the thing
that Kang needs Scots pin particles to
take or to retreat and then maybe Scott
once he realizes how evil Kang is
sabotage's King shifts that the energy
source just spills out everywhere now
back in my first trailer breakdown I
pointed out the visual similarity
between Kang's circular ringed City
structure and the 10 rings and this
golden structure does look a lot like
the 10 rings in the Shang cheapo's
credit scene when Wong projects their
forms and a Golden Glow emits from the
center which in that scene was a beacon
activating summoning someone or
something perhaps that Beacon was
calling to Kang his ship's power source
calling to him combine also by the way
it looks like Scott has to pile on top
of his variants to reach these bands
because notice how any variants that try
to grow to giant sized immediately
unravel this could be a security future
of the Bands anyone too big gets
disintegrated when they're too close so
it requires someone who can stay small
enough using pimp articles to pull off
this Heist notice how every new variant
of Scott that splits off immediately
extends their helmet over the face and
only the Scott that we follow keeps his
helmet off also a little detail I just
love the shot of Modoc with his mask
armored form totally has a little green
Vital sign and indicator on his chest
now when Scott falls from the Tower of
Ant-Man variants and gets buried in them
looks like hope van dying wasp is going
to swoop and rescue him but if you look
closely behind her I think her entering
this area causes an array of variants to
split off from her too now many have
pointed out how Kang's blue platform
looks a lot like Reed Richard's portal
and Multiverse Madness thing is a
descendant of Reed Richard so it makes
sense but it sounds like Kang is
building on the technology of many
Marvel heroes because that final shot of
Kang blasting energy from his wrists
seems like Kang is doing this out of
Rage the earlier shot showed him looking
out of the battle and one of his ships
is getting shot down by a green ship
Kang in this movie has been described as
quote no moves wasted but this energy
blast and scream seems like a bit of
wasted energy to me but notice how
Kang's scars light up blue when he does
this and the armor on his arms and his
shoulders lifts upward to free absorbs
so this suggests that Kang is a kind of
nanotech armor similar to The Mark 80s
suit that Tony Stark had an end game my
theory that Kang built on Tony Stark's
technology perhaps even stole Avenger
Tech as trophies after killing him you
guys remember Loki concept Dart had an
Iron Man helmet Trophy and he remains
action the theory is looking more and
more likely folks and I think is still
mad here because he's embarrassed to
have to show this to people hey another
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel launching February 17th so we
can celebrate quantumania day together
follow all of our socials there at Deep
dive at NR you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss calling
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
[Music]